that such health héctor mejía with his
briefing for today thursday august 12
nearly 200 parents protested last
night against the mandatory use of
masks in schools they
demonstrated outside the
main headquarters of the cis and to this the
parents did not  they want their children to be
forced to wear masks
inside establishments they say it
should be their own decision
state leaders put this rule
last week for all students
from kindergarten to grade
2 from now on
the district workforce  Clark county school
will be able to get tested at
pharmacies and the health district as of
Monday records that only 41
percent of the workforce is
vaccinated this number is expected to
increase as employees turn in
their proof of vaccination to the
system negative tests are
only for those who cannot
prove they have been vaccinated against  alcohol
meanwhile sisters entertainment is
looking for workers they have
more than 300 positions available at their 9 properties
on the las vegas strip the job fair
is today from 10 am to 2
pm those interested
should fill out the online application before applying
now a look at the
weather forecast we will have a mostly
sunny thursday with a high of 104 degrees
plus there should be a chance of storms in
the mountains and temps will rise
to end the week with 107 degrees
for friday more heat for the
weekend have a nice  Today I am Héctor
Mejía and this was your short news report on
Kirchner or in Spanish
[Music]